bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cette défiscalisation des
pourboires par carte bancaire est ce que
cette anecdotique ou bien c'est une
mesure avec un réel impact
bonjour déjà et merci de me recevoir je
pense que c'est une bonne chose je pense
que c'est une une bonne décision que
prend le gouvernement en en essayant de
revaloriser un petit peu plus les
salaires et en essayant de faire en
sorte que nos employés puissent
récupérer l'argent je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ne veulent pas
nous avons perdu
quel est l'objectif de cette mesure
expliqué nous à la fois renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat des professionnels du
secteur mais aussi renforcer
l'attractivité du secteur est ce qu'il
ya toujours un fort manque de personnel
alors c'est vraiment le problème majeur
actuellement c'est à dire que la suite
de la crise du coc vide avec de nombreux
mois d'interruption parce qu'on a eu
deux confinement 1 3 mois et demi en
sept mois et demi on s'est rendu compte
que de nombreux de nombreux employés en
changer de métier ou ont découvert la
vie tout simplement elles sont du compte
que les conditions de travail que nous
avons actuellement et qui font partie du
métier aujourd'hui une personne qui
travaille dans la restauration travail
forcément quand quand les autres ne
travaille pas on je pense on me dit je
pense au soir je tends ce soir et je
pense aux nuits c'est très compliqué
donc voilà c'est une petite mesure qui
va à mon avis avoir du sens et qui va
permettre aux serveurs de pouvoir
récupérer les pouvoirs sur les cartes
bleues aujourd'hui il ya très peu
d'affaires qui peuvent le faire parce
que quand vous prenez un paiement par
carte bleue vous êtes soumis à des taxes
à décharge et ressortir l'argent pour le
serveur directement en espèces c'est
très compliqué donc je pense que c'est
une très bonne mesure et on fait partie
des métiers aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
besoin de rendre attractif nos
professions nos activités donc on a
besoin de l'état pour ça et évidemment
ça passe par parra par la case salaires
et argent comme chaque fois est ce que
vous diriez que plus que les difficultés
financières aujourd'hui c'est surtout le
manque de personnel qui peut conduire à
la fermeture d'établissements
le manque de personnel il s'explique
parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu un désintérêt
vous savez aussi
au fil des années pour les métiers
manuels et on n'est pas les seuls
concernés je pense aux métiers du
bâtiment je pense à tous les métiers en
général où on a de plus en plus de mal à
recruter
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on arrive on a un
métier on a des métiers fabuleux on a un
savoir faire en france qu'il faut
protéger et qu'il faut mettre en avant
j'étais notamment au salon au sirha donc
à lyon le salon de l'hôtellerie et la
restauration on a vraiment un savoir
faire français qu'il faut protéger qu'il
faut mettre en avant et aujourd'hui il
faut se poser les bonnes questions il
faut revoir le système de formation il
faut pouvoir attirer à nouveau les
jeunes dans nos métiers parce que nous
avons des métiers moi j'en suis persuadé
qu'ils sont tout à fait passionnant et
on a besoin d'eux pour sa 2 de l'état on
a besoin de payer peut-être moins de
charges et revaloriser les salaires donc
il ya plein de solutions qu'on pourrait
arriver à proposer à l'état
maintenant il faut vraiment les mettre
sur la table parce que c'est très urgent
sinon on va aller à la catastrophe alors
justement l'état la restauration a perdu
deux tiers de son chiffre d'affaires est
ce que les aides de l'état vous ont
permis de tenir ces derniers mois
alors voilà il faut il faut être clair
c'est qu'on est beaucoup beaucoup de
chance en france par rapport au reste
des pays européens on a vraiment été
assistés on a vraiment été aidé par le
gouvernement donc là dessus il faut
reconnaître qu'ils ont fait leur travail
et ils ont permis à des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises de ne pas couler
de ne pas sombrer donc ça c'est très
bien maintenant on reprend un cycle
quasiment normal le problème c'est que
les chiffres d'affaires ne sommes pas
encore arrivés à ce qu'ils étaient il ya
encore deux ans et donc ça commence à
être compliqué ça commence à être
compliquée on a fait en général sur les
zones touristiques en fait en tout cas
nous sur la côte d'azur nous avons fait
une bonne saison cet été c'est un souci
mais il ya encore l'hiver qui arrive il
ya des mots qui vont être compliqués
donc voilà on peut pas sauver son
affaire avec deux mois de chiffre
d'affaires dans l'année donc il faut
rester quand même vigilant et il va y
avoir surtout les pga a commencé à
rembourser à partir d'avril 2022 donc là
dessus aussi on aimerait pouvoir avoir
un petit geste de l'état qui pour nous
permettre d'espacé un petit peu les les
paiements et ne pas les rembourser en
quatre ans mais peut-être avec des
annuités des annuités que l'on doit vous
nous dites que vous restez vie non mais
ce que vous êtes toutefois optimiste
pour l'avenir
il faut il faut rester optimiste et vous
savez je pense que les chefs
d'entreprises de toute façon trouver des
solutions quand il ya un problème
malheureusement on se rend compte qu'on
a de plus en plus de problèmes on a de
plus en plus de choses à gérer et
l'aspect du personnel en fait partie
l'aspect des salaires sans fait partie
également la fréquentation de nos
affaires on a le pass sanitaires aussi
au milieu donc on est optimiste de
nature un chef d'entreprise c'est un
leader c'est celui qui tire les wagons
derrière lui donc il faut qu'ils restent
optimistes mais ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de poids sur nos épaules et on
a besoin vraiment de pouvoir souffler un
petit peu et d'être aidés merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de réagir à sur rt
france seraient des intrants
vice-président de l'union des métiers
des industries de l'hôtellerie des alpes
maritimes